[Musique]
si je dis que vous êtes en vie à cause de ce que
vous avez apporté dans cet avion où diable
êtes-vous le bienvenu sur le podium, nous reconnaissons les personnes
examinées contenues et détruites,
mais ce que vous avez publié, ils n'aiment rien de
ce que j'ai jamais affronté
[Applaudissements  ]
elle m'a fait quelque chose
Je sais que
certains professeurs doivent envoyer un e-mail
où cela me laisse-t-il le choix
[Musique]
vous
depuis l'aube des temps le mal attaque
dans notre monde comme l'enfer
[Musique]
vous êtes vivant à cause de ce que vous avez
sur  terre tu as été choisi cinq mal
la légende du mal ultime l'
a à l'être d'
un pouvoir inimaginable
et elle vous utilise à nouveau vous deux
vous ne pouvez pas courir vous ne pouvez pas vous échapper
elle a des plans pour vous
maintenant nous dormons et
vous